we're taking a break you taking a break
with us I got Zakariya here half is
South Korea that's one of the miracles
of the Quran that millions upon millions
have memorizes no other book in the
world like the crown as CENTAC as the
Quran being memorized by so many
countless millions of people you a young
man at the age of what 20 hamdullah as
memorizes booking we're doing take a
break with the Quran the verbatim Word
of God
can you go ahead and share an ayah with
us from the verbatim what if God the
Quran please allah azza wajal he says in
the second chapter of the quran surat
al-baqara there will be learn him in a
shame on your regime was there a newbie
somebody was solar well in heaven you're
tuned in a little hot here in alonso gel
he reminds the believers and he says was
there any nobis somebody was allah and
to seek help and to seek assistance in a
need the savasana in in prayer
okay Allah Allah says and seek help and
aid in patience in prayer in like a
bureau tune in there a little harsher in
and that it is something great it is
something that is difficult and great in
their island ocean except those who are
submissive and humble towards allah
subhanaw taala
so let's let's take a break right let's
slow down let's think about what a lot
of a higher honor is is telling us right
a lot of us on a daily basis we have so
many problems in life so many issues you
know you couldn't you know if you were
to count the amount of problems that
happened to us on on a weekly basis on a
daily basis Yukie I mean they would go
past your fingers right more than so
many problems we have as human beings on
a daily basis now most Mahayana is
giving us the recipe is giving us the
secret here everyone wants an easy life
right everyone wants things to be you
know we all want help in life we all we
all want aid but almost funny is telling
us what to do I was there I noticed
somebody was sorta and seek seek aid and
seek assistance in patience in prayer
now the scholars the scholars they
mentioned that patience right that
summer is of three types right that you
have patience upon the the things that
was paralyzed me
incumbent upon us right to prayer Salah
but right to PR as a care you're
something you have to be patient upon
it's difficult sometimes sisters is
difficult to wear that hygienic but you
have to do it you have to be patient
Ryan you have to be patient the second
type of patients as a scholar is
mentioned is is being patient against
the things that Allah has Odin has been
prohibited upon us right iliza agencies
what i talkin abou seen and don't do
that come close to zina
why so gently he says do not consume the
wealth of the orphans right do not
consume alcohol all of these things that
Allah has made prohibited upon us
sometimes it's difficult but you have to
be patient you have to be patient and
the third type of patients as the
scholars mention is a Sabra a cadet in
there is being patient upon the decrees
of Allah and sometimes this is the most
difficult
your father passes away you're one of
your parents passes away your kids
something happens you lose your job
something happens that is purely out of
the decree of Allah subhana WA Ta'ala
and there's some time this is the most
difficult this is the most difficult so
that's something that we always have to
be patient upon is the is the the
decrease of Allah some of us something
happens to us we say oh it's God's fault
why me
right and this is something very
dangerous because we can't question the
wisdom of Allah subhanAllah
so Allah so Johnny he's saying was to a
notice of Allah and seek help and seek
aid in patience something you have to be
patient right this is something is very
important you have to be patient while
Sallah right and the prayer right the
prayer or lie if you were to pray these
silhouettes upon their times well I you
trust me you will see a difference in
your life alonzo Genesis in the sonnet
attend her and l-fatiha Immelman
co-writes Allah is a it prohibits all
types of lewdness and all types of evil
the solar will will you will see the
difference in your life when I want to
establish this or that so we ask Allah
so Allah then he makes us from amongst
those who establish the salah and from
amongst those who are patient and until
next time that's not want to thank you
very much that was another taking a
break with the quran thank you for
joining us hope you got the benefit I
surely did until next time peace be with
you
I said I'm